many of you have kids just as many of us
here do at channel 8.
you have a lot of questions about the
upcoming school year one place many of
you are getting answers
is a really popular facebook group 8
news now reporter kristen drummond shows
you how the online community
is now an important information resource
for parents
there's been some great things posted on
there alicia smith stays active with her
son's education
i consider myself an involved parent so
i like to
stay up on what's going on one place she
finds answers to questions
a facebook group called ccsd parents a
social media page with more than 12 000
members
and growing it's just a good resource
for parents to be able to reach out to
one another
and keep everyone abreast of what's
going on we started two years ago in
response to budget cuts
but now focuses on families sharing
ideas and getting information about the
district
three mothers including rebecca garcia
spend countless hours monitoring the
page
having a place where you can go ask
other parents a question
and get information you know we're
really seeing how many people in the
community appreciate that
along with members post the
administrators also arrange virtual
tutorials as well as q a
facebook live events previous virtual
meetings featured superintendent dr
jesus jarrah
ccsd educators and learning specialists
we have magnet and cta cta
principles this wednesday and then
on thursday we anticipate having a
back to school chat with elementary
principals communicating with the
community as
details evolve each day we try to fill
that gap
garcia recommends parents find
information specific to schools via
their website
but also encourages families to look at
school's social media platforms because
sometimes they're more up to date in the
newsroom kristen drummond 8 news now
another resource is connectingkidsnv.org
it's a website to help get students
devices and internet access
it just launched in a family resource
center will be live starting tomorrow
morning we have a link
over on our website